[Music]
also tonight more evidence of Americans
they're voting with their feet and with
their dollars as many families continue
to bolt High tax blue States like New
York and New Jersey Illinois Michigan
and California for low tax red States
like Texas and Florida Tennessee the
Carolinas we've shown you over and over
again the U-Haul index it shows that
California rank last on the growth index
and renting a U-Haul from California to
Texas is over three times as expensive
if you rent that same U-Haul from Texas
to California you do U-Haul a favor and
it's not only about taxes in States like
California far left lunacy continues to
dominate the day for example L.A County
recently purchased a 20 million dollar
Manhattan Beach property that was
returned to an African-American family
as a form of reparations and as one
longtime New Yorker who moved to Florida
writes in a new piece for foxnews.com
the great majority of people who contact
me are like us full of gratitude and
happiness that we got to sanity to
safety to normalcy by the way I hear
with reaction the author of that piece
Carol Markowitz along with The Epic
Times host Larry Elder Carol uh I read
your piece you left New York you were
you had a lot of Doubt uh by the way New
York just adopted a new law you can
compost grandma mom and dad when they
croak and you can put them in there with
the Alfalfa and the composting and you
can you can grow your your corn and your
flowers next year's using their dead
body as compost so what is the
difference between Florida and New York
well I'm really glad to hear that
because you know where else would what
else would we would we do with Grandma
um the thing is that when you're living
somewhere and you're thinking about
whether you should get out you should
ask yourself if you're just saying oh
things are bad or if you're thinking or
if you're saying to yourself things are
crazy and we got to where we were saying
things were crazy I was raised in
Brooklyn I grew up in 1980s Brooklyn
where things were dangerous but we
didn't have to argue that crime existed
it wasn't like convincing people that
like wow murder's gotten really bad but
in the in a time before we left New York
City we literally had to convince people
that the crime rate was spiking they
didn't believe it they thought crime was
just a lie told to them by Fox News and
the New York Post I mean it wasn't and
that's really where the city is right
now Larry Carol smart and we're dumb
you're in California I'm in New York
what's wrong with us
oh that's a good question John let me
say something about this reparations
thing uh it's a piece of property called
Bruce's Beach in an area called
Manhattan Beach and about a hundred
years ago through imminent domain uh not
just two Parcels of property which is
what the Bruce has owned 30 Parcels of
property were were acquired through
imminent domain only five of them were
blacks so did the 25 whites who lost
their property because of imminent
domain get reparations too furthermore
the two Primary people in this story are
the Bruce's they were represented by a
lawyer from the NAACP now this is
reparations how many slaves get lawyers
to negotiate their uh the amount of
money that they get for payment and
finally they were not chased out uh they
most of them moved to other parts of
Manhattan Beach this was a hundred years
ago what do current politicians have to
do with what 100 years ago politicians
did back then and watch the taxpayer
today be on the hook for what they did
back then
and finally Sean why don't we go to the
original sin California was once
occupied by so-called indigenous peoples
then the Spaniards then the Mexicans
we're going to give California oh back
to back to Mexico this is absurd all at
State can be just in its own time
when does it stop
Carol real quick don't give me any ideas
I don't think Larry should give them any
ideas that's true I think they're going
to end up arguing that we should give
them back to Mexico you guys will love
this I talked to Mike I talked to my
financial advisor once a year once a
year and they always say whatever you do
don't die in New York now I have another
reason not just the the inheritance tax
uh now I have to worry about my kids
turning me into compost and and growing
a garden over me I'm not so happy with
that idea
um anyway thank you both Carol thank you
and of course Larry we love having you
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else